things have not been going well for
right-wing news website Breitbart of a
trump advisor Steve ban and Fame there
Avenue the era their ad revenue has been
falling off a cliff more and more
companies have been pulling ad from the
website there's been a really great
social media shame campaign to get
advertisers to pull money from Breitbart
and there's now a new allegation against
Breitbart and it relates to the failed
candidacy of serial accused child sex
assault or Roy Moore in Alabama special
election a lawyer representing one of
Moore's accusers has come forward and
said that some of Roy Moore supporters
offered him money to drop the accuser as
a client now how does it involve
Breitbart part of the offer was that the
lawyer would make a specific statement
about dropping the accuser as a client
which would be released only and
directly to Breitbart news he would also
be paid ten thousand dollars and get the
pleasure I guess of being introduced
directly to Steven Bannon so this has
immediately raised questions about why
did he have to go to Breitbart with a
statement as part of the agreement why
would anyone even think to include that
was anyone involved in trying to pay off
the attorney to drop his client working
with or connected to Breitbart at
Breitbart in the first place and the
bigger question is is the allegation
credible and I don't really have trouble
believing that Breitbart and more
supporters would try to hurt the
accusers by getting that rid of their
legal representation
the only part that strikes me as less
believable is that they think they could
buy the lawyer with just ten thousand
bucks right you would imagine that
professional bribers know you've got to
offer more than ten grand to a lawyer to
get them to drop such a notable client
who's in the public eye and for what
it's worth the people named in the
article is being involved in reaching
out to the lawyer haven't denied doing
this they've simply said we did not do
anything wrong or illegal which is
basically like saying yeah we did it and
it was perfectly fine to do and the the
projection here is just stunning because
you'll remember that when the Washington
Post first broke some of the stories of
these accusers of Roy Moore yet
on the right who were saying the
Washington Post paid the women to make
up the stories now we love course there
was no evidence of that now we learn
that it actually might have been the
right trying to pay off the lawyers
representing the accusers so that they
would drop the cases and it is
absolutely pathetic and disgusting if
true the the there's a very clear silver
lining here though which is that
Breitbart really seems to be in disarray
and on its way down that is a really
great media story it remains to be seen
if they ultimately meet their total
demise but the latest allegations that
they were directly involved in this
truly and absolutely disgusting and will
continue to follow what ultimately
happens with Breitbart today's program
is sponsored in part by shaker and spoon
which is a really great monthly cocktail
subscription box that sends you the
craft cocktail experience right to your
door you get all of the ingredients you
need for three completely new original
recipes it's twelve total cocktails
worth I got for example the death by gin
box which gives me all of the
ingredients except for the gin for three
different gin-based cocktails I then go
out and get the gin that I like which in
my case is a dry gin my favorite of the
three drinks was the above a persimmon
love persimmons I've always loved
persimmons growing up not the most
popular fruit in my friend group is it a
fruit I guess technically it is but I
really like it and the above a persimmon
is a really really great drink my box
also came with the touristy gimlet and
the valet you get really easy to follow
instruction cards for each drink as well
as exactly how much of each ingredient
you need the right order to put it all
together I even found myself grating
nutmeg on top of one of the drinks and
the really great thing for me is that I
just hate throwing stuff out and a lot
of times when you need an ingredient for
something that you don't use for too
many recipes like for example I don't
cook with nutmeg too
I might buy a bunch of nutmeg and then
end up with a bunch left over and I
throw it out eventually I hate that I
hate wasting ingredients and that's the
great thing about the shaker and spoon
box that you actually get the amount of
each ingredient that you need and for a
limited time you can get $20 off by
going to shaker and spoon dot-com slash
Pakman link in the video description if
you're watching this on YouTube